at a railway station in Paris French
police step up patrols under Frances
strict lockdown rules only essential
travel is permitted but French
authorities are concerned that the start
of the school break and warmer weather
could tempt some people to leave home to
go on holiday we put in place new
measures and deployed more officers to
prevent all holiday travel because it's
not permitted France is in its fourth
week of confinement for people in the
city staying indoors isn't easy
and some have begun to linger outside in
the sunshine a little longer than
allowed but bumpy shoot is on something
you can't stop people from going out
they can cover their faces and minimize
risks but personally I think the
government like governments in many
countries misinformed us and did not
anticipate well enough in the
southwestern city of Bordeaux police are
tracking potential holidaymakers from
the air they're using helicopters to
increase surveillance of roads and the
region's motorways we saw and stopped
some people near the vers act toll road
they were trying to go on holiday they
were questioned by our colleagues on the
ground who are backing us up in the
sector one hour from Bordeaux the
picturesque village of up tousled bone
would usually be busy with tourists at
this time of year officials in southwest
France say that most people seem to be
obeying the lockdown but the extra
checks and surveys by police will
continue throughout the holiday period
the French government says the lockdown
is working that is preventing the
country's health system from being
overwhelmed
it's warned that if people start
breaking the confinement rules now the
collective effort made by so many over
the past weeks will have been for
nothing
Natacha butler al Jazeera Abdel Sudan
France